OpenGl can be used to create complex graphics
effects. This advanced OpenGL course from Victor
Gordan will take your skills to the next level.
Hi everyone! In this course I'll teach you about
different advanced topics in OpenGL that
will help you achieve more complex effects,
better looking renders, and more optimized
scenes. If you don't know what OpenGL is or
are not familiar with it, then you should first
watch the beginners course for OpenGL which you
can find on this channel. And that should be all
you need to know about this course, enjoy!
In this tutorial we'll take a look at Depth
Buffers in OpenGL and also see how we can make
use of them for a little graphical effect.
You might remember that we've already made
use of the Depth Buffer in the "Going 3D"
tutorial in order to fix a weird issue we had.
Since the buffer is turned off by default,
we want to make sure we have it enabled,
and that we clear it each frame just like the
Color Buffer. Now what this buffer basically does,
is that it stores "depth" values that represent
how far away from the near plane of the projection
matrix a certain fragment is. A depth value of
0 meaning that it's right on the near plane,
and of 1 meaning it's on the far plane.
Using this depth information, we can asses
which object should be in front of which other
object. We can do this by using the glDepthFunc
and inserting one of the following inputs. By
default OpenGL chooses GL_LESS which means that
if the depth value of an object is less than that
of the current depth value, then the first value
replaces the second. In most circumstances
you should use GL_LESS, but I suppose you
could also choose one of the others if you want
your game or application to be mind bending.
Now the cool part. Let's visualize the depth
buffer. We can easily do this by going to the
fragment shader and outputting gl_FragCoord.z as
the FragColor. The problem is, that as soon as
we press run, you'll notice the screen is mostly
pure white. The only way to see a bit of darkness
is to get very close to an object. This is due
to the fact that depth in OpenGL is not linear.
If the depth was linear, then we would have
the same amount of precision for depth at a
close distance as we would at a far away
distance. Since we almost always focus on
things that are close to us, we want to make the
precision be very high near us, and low away from
us. This is achieved by using this formula.
Don't worry, we don't have to implement it
since OpenGL does it automatically.
Sometimes though, you want to use another formula,
so in order to do that, we must first get the
z-value by linearizing the depth function, which
can be done using this function. Now using this
function we get the z value which keep in mind,
is not normalized. This value is simply the
distance from the near plane. So let's declare
the near and far constants of our frustum, and
divide the linear depth by the far length to
quickly normalize it just to see what the results
look like. Now let's just look at a quick problem
you can get, and then I'll show you the cool
effect we can achieve with depth buffers.
So the main issue that arises from depth buffers
is called Z-fighting, and it occurs because
two or more triangles have the same depth
buffer and thus the depth function can't
decide which one is closer than the other, and
thus it keeps changing between them constantly.
An easy fix to this is usually to make sure you
don't have triangles that are too close to one
another and parallel. If Z-fighting appears at a
far away distance, then you might also consider
tweaking the function of the depth buffer so
that you have more precision at that distance.
And the final trick is to use a bigger integer
for the depth buffer. Usually by default it uses
24bits, but you could change it to 32bits if your
card supports it. This will increase the precision
and thus decrease the change of Z-fighting.
Now for the cool effect. We can take the z value,
and plug it into a logistic function for
which we have a steepness parameter, and
an offset parameter. The steepness will control
how fast the depth value changes from close to 0
to close to 1, and the offset will determine
at what z-value this change is half way done.
The cool thing about this, is that this can give
you smooth edges for the end of your frustum
if you want that, but the even nicer thing, is
that this can somewhat simulate a fog effect.
So let's change our background color to a grey,
and calculate the depth value using our function.
Then multiply our usual direcLight() by the
reverse of our depth value, and also add the depth
value times the grey color from before. Now we
should have a nice simple fog effect. Keep in mind
that you might need to adjust the steepness
and offset a bit to get it just right.
Have fun playing around
with different effects!
In this tutorial we'll take a look at the
Stencil Buffer and how we can use it to create
useful effects such as outlining a model.
So the Stencil Buffer, just like the Depth Buffer,
holds a value for each pixel you can see, these
values being used for image masking in general.
Unlike the Depth Buffer though,
where each pixel holds between
2 and 4 bytes of data, for the Stencil
Buffer each pixel only holds 1 byte of data,
so values from 0 to 255. But you'll
mainly only use the values of 0 and 1.
So let's look at how we can work with this
new buffer. First of all we have the function
glStencilMask that allows us to choose which
parts of the Stencil Buffer we want to be able
to modify. It simply takes a pixel from the mask,
and a corresponding pixel from the Stencil Buffer,
and applies a bitwise "AND" comparison on them.
Keep in mind each pixel has a byte of data,
so 8 bits. A bitwise "AND" operation compares
each bit with it's corresponding counterpart and
only outputs 1 if they are both 1. Therefore if we
input 0x00 into glStencilMask, which means that we
have 8 bits equal to 0, then all the comparisons
will fail and the Stencil Buffer won't change
at all. But if we input 0xFF into glStencilMask,
then all the bits of the mask will be 1 since
0xFF is equal to 8 ones, and so we'll be able
to modify any part of the Stencil Buffer.
Now let's look at two more functions we can
make use of: glStencilFunc, and glStencilOp.
glStencilFunc allows us to control how the
Stencil Buffer passes a test or fails a test,
while glStencilOp allows us to dictate
what happens when the stencil test fails,
when the stencil test passes but the
depth test fails, and when both pass.
Let's take a deeper look at glStencilFunc.
It takes in three arguments: a function,
a reference value, and a mask. The function can
be one of these, by default being set to GL_ALWAYS
so the test always passes. The reference value
is simply the value we use to compare in the
function. Notice how before comparing the stencil
value with the reference value we apply a bitwise
AND operation to both using the mask. This means
that if you want to compare the numerical value
of the two accurately you will want your
mask to be 0xFF so that nothing changes.
Now for glStencilOp, it has four arguments: sfail,
dpfail, and dppass. These stand for stencil fail,
depth fail, and depth pass. For all of
these you can choose between the following
options. By default they all have GL_KEEP
which basically means that nothing changes.
There's not really much more to say about these
functions, so if you want to know more about them,
look them up in the documentation.
The Stencil Buffer can be used for many
things such as portals, mirrors, and more, but an
easy feature to implement is outlining of models,
so let's take a look at that. We first want to
render our object like we normally do and update
the stencil buffer with 1s everywhere we have
a fragment from our object, and 0 everywhere we
don't have a fragment from our object. This
will essentially create a figure like this.
Then we want to disable writing to the stencil
buffer so we don't accidentally modify it,
and also disable depth testing so that we can make
sure the next object we draw will be completely in
front of the previous one. Now we want to render
a scaled up version of the object we had before,
but this time in a flat color, and with the
following condition: we only draw it's fragments
where the stencil value is not 1, so basically not
where the silhouette of the previous object was.
Then we just restore writing to the
stencil and enable the depth buffer
again. That's all we have to do.
Now let's implement it in code. We
start of by enabling our stencil buffer using
glEnable(GL_STENCIL_TEST), and making sure we
also have our depth buffer enabled. Then we
use glStencilOp plugging in GL_KEEP, GL_KEEP,
and GL_REPLACE. This will make it so that
when both the depth and stencil tests pass,
we'll use the reference value specified by
glStencilFunc. Now let's make sure we clear
all the buffers before each frame, and go
on to the part where the magic happens.
First we specify our stencil test always
passes, and set the reference value to 1.
Then we enable writing to all of our stencil
buffer with a stencil mask of all 1s. And now
we simply draw our object. By this point in time,
our stencil buffer looks like this, and our color
buffer like this. Remember that all these values
are 1 because we specified in the glStencilOp
function that if both the stencil and depth
tests pass, then make the pixel of the stencil
buffer equal to 1. Now for the outline we want our
stencil test to only pass when it's not equal to 1
and the depth test passes. Then we disable out
depth buffer for previously mentioned reasons,
and disable writing to the stencil mask
so we can keep our original silhouette.
Now since we want to make the outline a flat
color, we'll have to create two new shaders,
and a shader program. So let's first create the
shader program like so. Then for "outlining.frag"
we simply want to return a color, while for
"outlining.vert" we want to get the position,
and all the uniforms related to transformations,
plus a new float uniform called outlining,
which we'll multiply with the scale matrix. Now
back in the main function we'll want to send
that outlining uniform to the shader with a value
of something like 1.08. Then we simply draw the
same object again, but this time using the other
shaders. The last step we need to do is to enable
writing to the whole stencil, clear it by always
passing the test and replacing the values with 0,
and enabling the depth buffer. Now if
you run the program, you should see
an outline around your object. If your object
has it's origin at its geometrical center and
if it doesn't have very complex shapes, then the
outline probably looks fine. In my case though,
you can see that the origin is not at the center
since the outline is skewed upwards, and that
the shapes are pretty complex, with many curves,
therefore this method won't work that well.
A better method that doesn't take much would
be to import the normals in the vertex shader,
and add those to the position vector, multiplying
them by the outlining, which we'll remove from the
scale matrix, and which we'll now lower from
1.08 to 0.08. Now when scaling the vectors,
instead of scaling them from their origin, we
are sort of scaling them outwardly from the model
using the normal as a reference for what "outward"
means. This will give you much better results,
with one exception. If you have hard
edges, then your normals will be close
to perpendicular to one another and so will
create a little gap when expanding the model.
Therefore a third solution to this would be to
simply have another model that's bigger than
the first one. To be more specific, it has to be
thicker, not necessarily bigger. You can achieve
something like this using Blender's solidify
modifier. Here you can see I have the initial
model, and the bigger version of it. Now I've
already exported both as different models, and I
only have to import them into my program like so.
Then instead of drawing the object a second time,
I simply draw the bigger version of it, this
time not even needing a uniform to scale it.
And as you can see, this gives the best results,
though at the cost of doubling the storage cost...
You could of course make a function similar
to the solidify function that blender has,
but that would be slightly more
complicated for this tutorial.
Today I'll show you what face culling
is, and how it affects performance.
We are also gonna measure this performance
change by making an FPS counter.
So face culling is a step in the graphics pipeline
that decides if a triangle will move on to the
fragment shader (aka, if the triangle will be
drawn or not). OpenGL decides this by seeing
which side of the triangle is currently facing the
camera. Generally speaking, in most 3D graphics
programs, it is the front side of a triangle
that is sent to the fragment shader, and the
back side of a triangle that is discarded.
The way OpenGL figures out which side is which,
is by an index convention, which can either
be clockwise, or counter-clockwise. In a
counter-clockwise framework, if the order of the
indices of a triangle are counter-clockwise when
facing us, then the side we see, is the front
side. Likewise, if the order of the indices of a
triangle are clockwise when facing us, then the
side we see, is the back side. For a clockwise
framework it's the exact opposite. Most graphics
programs use a counter clockwise standard,
but don't expect all of them to use this.
Now in order to put all of this into code,
we just have to enable the face culling
using glEnable with GL_CULL_FACE,
specify which face we want to keep, 99% of the
time that will be GL_FRONT, and then specify the
standard we want to use. Again I suggest using
the counter-clockwise one since from what I've
seen it's more common than the clockwise one.
Now if we run the program, you'll notice that
when we get inside an object, we won't be able
to see its insides, since it contains the backs
of the triangles, which get discarded.
Therefore we only see the background.
So let's see if this makes any difference in
performance. For that we'll need an FPS counter,
which I'll display in the title of the window.
Let's start by creating three doubles for
the previous time, the current time, and the
difference of these two. Then we also want an
unsigned integer that will act as a counter
to see how many frames we have in a certain
amount of time. Now, FPS, is simply the
amount of frames you get in a second.
So that means that in order to get the FPS, we
can count the number of frames we get in a second,
a frame being one loop in our main while loop.
But that would also mean that our FPS will get
updated only once a second. Instead let's
update it every 30th of a second for example.
To do that we just need to get the current time
in seconds using glfwGetTime, the time difference,
and increment the counter. Then if the difference
is higher or equal to a 30th of a second,
we go ahead with the measurement of the FPS.
The FPS will simply be equal to 1 divided by the
time difference, which is the amount of frames
in a second that this time difference gives,
but the time difference contains multiple frames,
which are equal to the counter, so we also need to
multiply it with the counter as well. Now we could
stop here, but it's also useful to know how long
a frame takes in terms of milliseconds. To do
that we simply divide the time difference by
the counter which gives us the number of seconds
a frame takes, and then multiply that by 1000 to
transform it into milliseconds. Then we simply
put together the new title and apply it to the
window using glfwSetWindowTitle. Then we want
to set the previous time as the current time
in order to get the time difference back
to 0, and also set the counter to 0.
Now if you start your program, you'll be able
to see the amount of frames you have. If they
are stuck on 60, then that means that you have
VSync on, which tries to keep your FPS constant
to 60 frames per second. If you wish to disable
this, then write glfwSwapInterval(0) in your
main function. Keep in mind that this will only be
able to deactivate VSync if VSync is not forced by
your graphics driver. In any case, I recommend
keeping it at 60 frames per second. But if you
don't want to do that, at least make sure that the
functions that handle user inputs are put into an
if statement that works periodically like this
one, otherwise the responsiveness of your inputs
will vary with your FPS, which you do not want.
And just to show you that face culling improves
your FPS, here is a very high resolution model
and the difference in FPS. The difference is not
big here, but it's noticeable in the numbers.
When you have multiple models and a lot of
stuff happening, the difference will
become even more noticeable.
In this tutorial I'll show you how to
quickly get transparency turned on,
and also how to make use of the
blending feature in OpenGL.
So as you might have noticed, all the textures
we've been using so far had 4 components: RED,
GREEN, BLUE, and ALPHA (RGBA). The first three
of those give color to our scene, while the
last one controls the level of transparency
different objects have. Now if you look at
this grass model I have imported you'll notice
there is no transparency to it. To enable that
we simply have to create a new fragment shader
which will be identical to our normal fragment
shader, but we'll check if the alpha value is
smaller than a certain threshold, and if it is,
we'll discard that fragment. Don't forget to
also make a new shader program for this new
fragment shader. So if you run the program, you
should see the grass is now as it should be.
Now I'll just add a bunch of randomly placed
transparent windows. Since the code here is not
relevant to OpenGL I won't be explaining it. The
shader I use for these is a very basic shader that
just displays the textures without any lighting.
So now as you can see there are a bunch of
WINDOWS, but even though in my texture they
are see-through, here they are not. In order to
achieve a see-through effect we need blending.
Now for a bit of theory. This is the formula
OpenGL uses for blending different colors
together. All the C terms stand for Color,
while the T terms stand for transparency.
Which in case you didn't know or forgot,
an alpha level of 0 is fully transparent and an
alpha level of 1 is fully opaque. And then the
source color is the color in the fragment shader,
while the destination color is the color in the
color buffer. These transparencies can have
different formulas. The most common one is that
in which the source gets its transparency value
from the alpha part of the source color, while
the destination's transparency is 1 - the alpha
value of the source. So now let's tell OpenGL we
want to use this configuration using glBlendFunc
specifying the source and destination functions.
Here is a list of some functions you might want
to use for one reason or another. Then if you
want to you can also use glBlendEquation with one
of these arguments in order to specify how you
want the previous colors to interact, basically
changing the default equation. And lastly you can
use the glBlendFuncSeparate function to choose how
to interact with the RGB channel, and the alpha
channel for both the source and destination.
Keep in mind you can't specify a function for
each RGB value, only for all of them together.
At this point we just have to enable blending
using glEnable(GL_BLEND) right before our windows,
and then disable it right after we are done
drawing them so that we don't accidentally affect
anything else. You should always do this with
transparent objects. After that just compile and
you should see that the windows are transparent.
But there is one problem... the blending is all
messed up. It just doesn't look right. And for
that we have our friend the Depth Buffer to blame.
Since the windows are drawn in a random order,
windows that are drawn behind already existing
ones don't get drawn at all since the depth test
fails. So in order to draw all the windows
we should draw the furthest one first, and
the closest one last. Or you could of course be
lazy about it and simply disable the depth buffer
when drawing the windows, but that will not work
in most circumstances, and I would not recommend
it usually. Another option would be to sort the
windows by their distance from the camera.
Now sorting has nothing to do with OpenGL, so
I won't be explaining this part, and I actually
encourage you to come up with your own solution
for sorting the windows. The important thing
is that I calculate all the distances from one
window to the camera by subtracting the window
position from the camera position and getting the
length of that vector. Then based on that length
I sort all my windows from the furthest to the
closest and draw them. It's that simple! You just
have to be a bit creative with the sorting part
and how you store your objects. Just keep in mind
that this method where you just draw the objects
in order is not guaranteed to work 100% of the
time. If different transparent objects intersect
or do some weird stuff, you will get weird
results. But other methods are pretty complicated
so for now this will have to do.
In this tutorial I'll show you how to implement
a custom framebuffer into your OpenGL application
and how you can use the framebuffer
to achieve post processing effects.
So first of all, what is a framebuffer?
Well you can think of a framebuffer as a
collection of multiple buffers that result
in the final image you see on your screen.
So it contains a color buffer, a depth buffer, and
a stencil buffer. Now why would you want to use
one? Well if we create our own framebuffer,
then we can display it on a rectangle that
covers the whole screen and then using shaders
modify the pixels displayed on the rectangle
to achieve different effects. This is called
post-processing because you process the pixels
after all the rendering has already been done.
Ok, now let's implement the framebuffer. Just like
any OpenGL object, we create an unsigned int, we
generate the framebuffer using glGenFramebuffers,
and we bind it. That was it for the framebuffer.
Now we need to add a color texture for it to be
of any use. So we'll create a texture just like
in the textures tutorial, making sure we clamp
the texture to the edges since otherwise certain
effects will bleed from one side of the screen
to the other due to the default repetition of the
texture. Then we simply attach the texture to the
framebuffer using glFramebufferTexture2D.
Keep in mind we store our color in a texture,
therefore we can access it from a shader, which we
want to do. But in the case of the depth buffer,
we don't really care about reading it in a shader
for this tutorial, so instead of using a texture,
we can use a Render Buffer Object which
is much faster but has the disadvantage
that you can't read it directly in a shader. We
create it using glGenRenderbuffers, and then we
configure its storage using glRenderbufferStorage,
plugging in GL_RENDERBUFFER, GL_DEPTH24_STENCIL8,
and the width and height. We use
GL_DEPTH24_STENCIL8 so that we can store in it
both the stencil buffer and depth buffer. Also be
very careful that all the framebuffers components
have the same width and height, otherwise you
might get an error. Then we just attach it to the
framebuffer using glFramebufferRenderbuffer.
And for a bit of error checking,
just write this. Sadly the errors are not very
specific, they just give you a number. Here are
the meanings of the errors you can get.
Now that we have the framebuffer object,
we can make our rectangle which will always
cover the whole screen, and so we don't want to
apply any sort of transformations to it. Now let's
create two very basic shaders for the framebuffer,
make them into a shader program, and
then send the unit of our texture,
0 since it's the only texture in this shader.
Now let's handle the drawing part. First we make
sure to bind the framebuffer before we draw
anything, including the background. Make
sure your buffers are cleared and that you
have depth testing enabled after that. Then
after we are done drawing everything in the scene,
we want to switch back to our default framebuffer
by binding 0, and draw the rectangle which
displays the framebuffer we've just unbinded.
Just make sure to disable depth testing so that
the rectangle doesn't fail the depth test.
Now if you run the program you should be seeing
whatever you were seeing before without any
difference. If your screen is a flat color, then
first check that you don't have any errors in
your cmd-like window, then make sure your face
culling isn't getting rid of the rectangle (so
either change the order of the vertices, or
disable culling when drawing the rectangle).
For any other errors check the source code
in the description and look through your
code very carefully, there are a lot of
things that can go wrong in this case.
Ok, now let's make this interesting. In
the framebuffer fragment shader we can do
all kinds of interesting effects. Some easy
ones would be inversing the colors like so,
or making the image black and white. But these
are not that interesting. To get more interesting
results, we want to sample multiple pixels when
we choose the color of a single pixel. For that
we first want to declare an array of vec2s which
will represent the offset from the pixel we are on
to its 8 neighbours. Notice how I divide 1 by 800
to get the width and height of one pixel for my
800 by 800 window. After that we want to create a
float array which will represent something called
a kernel. It's basically a matrix that helps
us achieve cool effects by sort of defining how
important each pixel is in relation to the pixel
we are currently on, that being the one in the
middle. Generally speaking you probably want
them to be somewhat symmetrical and always add
up to 1. If they add up to more than 1 the final
color will be brighter, and if they are under 1,
the final color will be darker. Here though they
add up to 0, but that is intentional since this
is an edge detection kernel and I want everything
to be really dark, except the edges of things.
Now all we have to do is to multiply each part of
the kernel with each pixel at a certain offset and
add up all of them in this vec3 named color.
Just keep in mind that even though these look
like matrices, we don't actually multiply them the
same way we do matrices. Then the last step is to
output color as the FragColor, and we're done!
I think this kernel gives a pretty cool effect.
Here are some other kernels you might want to
try out. I suggest you just play around with
this a bit and make your own kernels so that
you get a feeling as to how they work.
In this tutorial I'll show you
what cubemaps are in OpenGL,
and how you can use them to create skyboxes.
So what are cubemaps? Well they are simply another
type of texture, which holds 6 2D textures, one
for each side of a cube. When sampling a cubemap,
you specify a 3D vector instead of a 2D one.
This allows you to easily sample between
all 6 sides of the cube. And since the coordinates
of the cube correspond to the sampling vectors,
there is no need for UVs. The most common uses for
cubemaps are quadsphere texturing and skyboxes.
So now let's code it in. The first thing you
need to do is to write out the cube vertices
and indices. Then we'll want to create a VAO,
VBO, and EBO just like in the first tutorials.
Now let's create an array with 6 strings that will
hold the paths to the 6 images we'll be using for
the skybox. Then we want to create the cubemap
texture itself just like any other texture,
except that where we put GL_TEXTURE_2D
before, we not put GL_TEXTURE_CUBE_MAP.
Make sure to clamp the texture in all three
directions since the texture is a cube,
therefore 3D. This clamping should
prevent any seams from showing up.
And now we'll go over all six textures and read
them using the stb library, putting them in the
cube texture once we read them. Notice how I
disable the vertical flipping. This is because
unlike most textures in OpenGL, cubemaps are
expected to start in the top left corner,
not the bottom left corner. Also notice how
I add i to GL_TEXTURE_CUBE_MAP_POSITIVE_X.
This represents the side of the cube
I am currently assigning a texture to,
and I am adding i to it in order to cycle through
all the sides. Here is the order of the sides
which you can find in the OpenGL docs, and here is
the order we wrote the paths in. Notice something
weird? Well, normally in OpenGL, the front is
in the negative Z direction, but for cubemaps,
the front is in the positive Z direction. That
means that cubemaps work in a left-handed system,
while most of OpenGL works in a right-handed
system. This can be very confusing, and I honestly
have no idea why they chose to do this, but oh
well. Keep in mind you will likely get small
bugs because of this if you are not careful. In my
case, my right texture kept being displayed upside
down for some reason. To fix that I just flipped
the texture in an image editor. So be prepared for
this sort of stuff since from what I've heard
it can happen pretty often with skyboxes.
Ok, back to the tutorial. We'll now need to
create two shaders for the skybox. The vertex
shader will take in the coordinates, output
texture coordinates, and also take in uniforms
for matrix transformations. In the main function
create a vec4 which holds the final transformed
coordinates. Now since these coordinates are now
in screen space, we'll do something a bit weird.
Instead of feeding gl_Position the coordinates
as they are, we'll give it the x, y, w,
and again w components. This will result
in the z component always being 1 after
the perspective division. And since the depth
buffer takes the z component as its depth value,
the skybox will always have a depth value of
1, so the furthest depth value possible, thus
being behind all objects, as it should be. And
finally we want to export the texture coordinates
as the positions, except we'll flip the z axis
to combat the coordinate system change.
For the fragment shader we just want to import the
texture coordinates, the cubemap, and then set the
fragColor to equal the texture. That's it.
Back in the main function I'll create a shader
program and export the skybox texture unit.
All that's left now is the drawing part.
We'll start by setting the depth function
to GL_LEQUAL instead of the default GL_LESS
since our skybox is right on the edge, aka 1, so
we need that equal sign. Then we'll activate the
shader and create the view and projection matrices
which are identical to the ones we created in the
camera class, except for one small detail. For
the view matrix, we downgrade it to a mat3, and
then we scale it back up to a mat4. This will make
the last row and column of the matrix equal to 0,
thus having no effect on translations.
We only want the skybox to rotate,
not move around. Then simply export
these matrices to the vertex shader.
Now the final part is to draw the cubemap itself
just like any other object, except that when
we bind the texture, we use GL_TEXTURE_CUBE_MAP
instead of the usual GL_TEXTURE_2D. Don't forget
to switch the depth testing to it's default
GL_LESS after you are done with the skybox.
If you boot up your program, you should now have
a nice skybox all around you. If any of the faces
are inverted or something like that, play around
with the orientation of your images in an image
editor. Trust me, it's a lot easier to just do
that rather than trying to find a little logic bug
caused by the two different coordinate systems,
and the different texture reading origins. If you
have seams that are clearly lines, then you can
try adding glEnable(GL_TEXTURE_CUBE_MAP_SEAMLESS)
somewhere in your code. If your seams are
not lines, but simply clear differences in
color between one face and another, then you
probably just have a shitty skybox. If you
can't see anything or only parts of the skybox,
then you probably have back face culling enabled
and wrote the indices in the wrong
winding order. Simply disable face
culling when drawing the skybox, or write the
indices in the correct winding order.
In this tutorial I will show you what the
geometry shader is and how you can use it
to create things such as visible normals.
So far we've only used the vertex shader,
and fragment shader, which suffice in most
situations. But sometimes between the vertex
and fragment shaders you want to have an extra
step to modify the geometry of your meshes.
Even though it might seem like you can do that
in the vertex shader, you can only do things to
individual vertices. If you wanted to modify a
whole triangle, so a group of vertices, then you
would need to use the geometry shader. The second
advantage of the geometry shader is that it can
switch between different types of primitives,
and so can create or delete vertices.
So let's begin by adding the geometry shader to
our shader class. Notice how I am doing the exact
same thing as for the other two shaders,
except that I use GL_GEOMETRY_SHADER. Now
that we support custom geometry shaders, let's
create a geometry shader that does nothing.
Just like any other shader we'll begin with the
version. Then we need two layouts written like so.
The first layout signifies what type of primitive
we receive, which can be one of the following,
while the second layout shows what
type of primitive we are outputting,
which can be one of the following. In
this case we want to receive a triangle
and export a triangle. Then we have our outputs to
the fragment shader. Keep in mind you should pass
data from the vertex shader to the geometry
shader and then to the fragment shader.
Now for importing data into the geometry shader,
we need to do something a bit different. Instead
of simply having an "in", we'll have a sort of C
structure written out like so. Note that we don't
have to include the position in this because
it is already built into a default structure
just like this one called gl_in. Now we need to
go back to the vertex shader and replace all the
outgoing data with the exact same structure except
for this last part and "out" instead of "in".
Make sure that everything else from the structure
is identical to its counterpart in the geometry
shader. Notice how I also included the projection
matrix. That is because we only want to apply the
projection matrix AFTER we modify our geometry.
Now to assign data to these outgoing values
we simply write the name we gave them plus a dot
and the name of the variable we want to assign
data to. Very similar to a C or C++ structure.
Now in the geometry shader we have all the data
we need, so all that's left to do
is to assemble this data together.
To do that we simply assign the position, normal,
color, and texture coordinates their data. Notice
how here I also have an index besides the name of
the part of the structure I want to access. That's
because we are in the geometry shader and thus
we essentially have an array of such structures,
each with different values for a specific vertex.
Once we are done assigning the values of a vertex,
we must use EmitVertex() to declare that we
are done with this vertex, VertEx veRTeX veRtEx
vERTeX. Now we can do the same thing for the other
two vertices, and once we are done with all three
vertices we need for a triangle, we declare that
our primitive is complete using EndPrimitive().
And that was it for the default geometry
shader. If you run your program you should
have exactly what you had before, amazing!
But that's really boring, so let's change things
up a bit and make the geometry shader more fun.
Something that is extremely easy to do is to
calculate the surface normal using a cross product
and then add that normal to the three positions of
the primitive. This will make your meshes look as
if all the primitives exploded or glitched out.
Now let's do something a bit more serious.
Let's create a new shader which will take our
default vertex shader, a new fragment shader,
and a new geometry shader. And let's draw our
model using this shader after we draw it using the
default shader. Now for the fragment shader we'll
simply output a flat color, nothing fancy.
But for the geometry shader, we'll get a triangle,
and output not a triangle, but multiple lines!
So now we are actually destroying and creating
new geometry since as you can see we'll output 6
vertices even though we only got 3. Then we'll use
the exact same structure, and in the main function
we'll simply retrieve the first vertex position
and declare it. But then instead of moving to
the next vertex, we'll remain on this one but
add to it the normal of the vertex and then emit
it. This essentially creates a line across the
normal of the vertex. Now we want to do the same
for the other vertices, but in order to not link
all the lines together we must first end this
line by using EndPrimitive and then move on.
After doing this for all the vertices we
can press play and see that we are now able
to visualize all the normals of our model which
can be pretty useful for debugging purposes.
Keep in mind that geometry shaders can
also be very useful for things such as
grass or subdividing models. So they
are actually pretty interesting.
In this tutorial I'll show you what Instancing is
and how you can use it to massively improve the
performance and looks of your OpenGL project.
So instancing is simply a feature that allows you
to draw a mesh multiple times in a single
draw call. Now why would you want this?
Well consider these scenarios where I have a belt
of asteroids all made out of a single asteroid
mesh that is deformed in the vertex shader to give
some variety. In the scenario on the left I simply
have a loop that draws each asteroid individually.
So that means that each asteroid has a draw call.
Now in the scenario on the right I draw all the
asteroids together. So that means that I only have
a single draw call. If you look at the performance
difference, you'll see it is massive.
Now let's code it in. I'll start with the
code already written for the first scenario
since it's nothing new for this series. So in
order to enable instacing, all we have to do
is to use glDrawElementsInstanced instead of
glDrawElements, and add at the end of it how
many instances of the mesh we want. The only
problem is that this will draw all the meshes
in the exact same positions, so it is useless.
There are multiple ways you could move each mesh
to a unique position though. You could have code
that does that in the vertex shader for example.
Using gl_InstanceID you'll get the index of
the the instance you are currently drawing,
and so you can use that for controlled random
number generation. Alternatively you could have a
uniform with all the transformations and retrieve
the correct transformation for a specific instance
using gl_InstanceID. But the problem with this
is that uniforms can't store that much data. So
the best way to have a lot of transformations and
not have the generation inside the vertex shader
is to store the transformations inside a vertex
buffer that is attached to the VAO of the mesh.
So let's start by creating a VBO constructor
which takes a vector of mat4s. Then we want
to add an unsigned integer public variable to
the Mesh class that will signify the amount of
instances we desire. And of course we also need
to add it to the constructor to easily change it.
Also in the constructor we should add the vector
of matrix transformations for the instances
so that we can plug it into the vertex buffer.
Now in the Mesh.cpp file we want to create a VBO
for the instances and then link its attributes to
the VAO only if we are drawing more than one mesh.
Make sure to link the matrix as 4 different vec4s
since otherwise your program won't work. And at
the end use glVertexAttribDivisor plugging in the
layout number of each vec4 and 1. This 1 means
that the vec4 will be used for a whole instance.
If it were 0, then the vec4 would be used for
a vertex, and then the next vec4 will be used
for the next vertex, which we for sure don't
want. And just to make it clear, if it were
2 it would be used for two instances before
switch to the next vec4. Now let's also
limit the use of glDrawElementsInstanced
only for multiple instances.
For the Model class we need to do the
exact same thing as for the Mesh class where
we add instanceMatrix to the constructor and
as a variable, and instancing as a
variable yet again. Now in our loadMesh
function we want to include the instancing and
instanceMatrix in the Mesh creation process.
Now we need a slightly modified shader
for instance drawing to accommodate for
the new layout. So create a new shader program
specifically for the asteroids using a special
vertex shader and the default fragment shader.
The vertex shader will be identical to the
default one except we'll have a 5th layout for the
instanceMatrix, we'll delete the uniforms we don't
need, and replace all transformations with just
the instanceMatrix one. Don't forget to export the
lighting uniforms in the main function as well.
Then all that's left to do is to merge the
translation, rotation, and scale matrices together
and add all of them to the instanceMatrix vector.
Then simply add that and the instancing number
to the Model constructor of the asteroids,
and draw the asteroids once. Remember that
we only need to call the draw function once.
Now compile and witness thousands upon thousands
of asteroids with a minimal performance impact. Of
course keep in mind that the performance
will differ from one GPU to another,
so it might not work as well on yours
as it would on someone else's.
In this tutorial I'll show you
what Anti-Aliasing is and how
you can implement it in your OpenGL project.
So you might have noticed that while horizontal
and vertical edges look extremely crisp,
diagonal edges tend to look a bit choppy,
like a flight of stairs. This is due to how
we display images on our screens. Since our
displays are made out of a bunch of tiny squares,
aka pixels, it is impossible to have a smooth line
on the diagonal. But thankfully, we can
fake smoothness by bleeding the color of
an edge into the adjacent pixels like so.
Now, these jagged edges are called Aliasing,
and an Anti-Aliasing technique is what helps us
get better edges. There are multiple techniques
for Anti-Aliasing each with their advantages
and disadvantages, but today I'll focus on MSAA
which stands for Multi Sampling Anti-Aliasing.
So what does this Multi Sampling refer too?
Well in the rasterization part of the pipeline
primitives are filled in. The way it is decided
which pixels should be given a color and which
should not, is by checking if the sample point
of a pixel, which is normally in the center of it,
is inside the shape of the primitive. This means
that if the sample point is even just slightly
outside the triangle, it won't get sampled,
even though you would think it should at least do
so partially. Well, that is where MSAA comes in.
As you might have guessed, this technique
simply adds multiple sampling points so
that a more accurate result can be reached.
Here for example, two out of the 4 sampling points
are inside the triangle, and so the color of that
pixel will be somewhere between the color of the
background and the color of the primitive.
Now let's actually implement this. Let's start
off by creating a variable where we specify how
many samples we desire. Now, if you don't have a
framebuffer, then you can just give a window hint
to GLFW saying you want GLFW_SAMPLES and then the
number of samples you want, and then activate
GL_MULTISAMPLE. That was it for this tutorial,
as... nah I'm joking. But for real though, if you
don't have a framebuffer that's all you have to
do, you are done. If you do have a framebuffer,
then you'll want to delete the GLFW part.
Instead you need to go to your framebuffer
and replace all GL_TEXTURE_2D with
GL_TEXTURE_2D_MULTISAMPLE. Then replace
glTexImage2D with glTexImage2DMultisamples,
plugging in the type of texture, the number of
samples, the color format, the width, the height,
and whether or not you want all samples to be
in the exact same position in the pixels.
Then for the renderbuffer object we need
to change from glRenderbufferStorage
to glRenderbufferStorageMultismaple and
add the number of samples we want.
Now the problem is that we can't do any sort
of post-processing on this framebuffer anymore
since it has multisampling enabled. So to get
around that we'll need a normal framebuffer
which we can post-process. This is just like
the one I made in the framebuffer tutorial.
Now in the main function we want to make
sure we first bind the multisampling FBO,
clear the screen, clear the buffers, and enable
depth testing. Then we draw everything we want
to draw. After that we bind the multisampling
FBO as read only, and the postprocessing FBO as
draw only. Now using glBlitFramebuffer
we'll resolve all the multisampling and
copy the result onto the post-processing FBO.
Now make sure you bind the default framebuffer
and draw the framebuffer rectangle using the
postprocessing texture. Run the program and
you'll see that the edges of primitives are
a lot smoother and nicer. Just be aware that
applying kernels in the post processing will
essentially overwrite the anti aliasing and so
you may end up with aliasing again. As
for the number of samples you should use,
I suggest using either 2, 4, or 8. You can
go up to 16 and 32 on some GPUs but the
improvement/performance ratio is not worth it.
That was it for this tutorial, as always the
source code and all resources used
are in the description. Bye!